there is no more British value than our  commitments to protect and honor those  who built the country we live in so to  support the poorest pensioners I have  decided to increase the pension credit  by 10.1 percent which is worth up to  1470 pounds for a couple of 960 pounds  for a single pensioner in our most  vulnerable pension on our most  vulnerable households  but the cost of living crisis is harming  not just our poorest pensioners but all  pensioners  so because we've taken difficult  decisions elsewhere today I can also  announce that we will fulfill our pledge  to the country to protect the pension's  triple lock  [Applause]  in April in April the state pension will  increase in line with inflation and 870  pounds increase which represents the  biggest ever increase in the state  pension and to the millions of  pensioners who will benefit from this  measure I say now and always this  government is on your side